so nice to meet you guys I love that I
love the fits I love the looks
likewise thank you I love your posters
thank you so much and I also you know
obviously loved the show you guys are
wonderful and I think the first thing
that I wanted to start with is that I
see so much of mad Mart again and sorsha
in in kit and Eric and I was wondering
did you guys look to those characters
sort of specifically when you were sort
of finding inspiration since they're
your parents or did you say you know no
I'm gonna leave that as it is I'm not
gonna worry about you know how much
influence that has on me and sort of
just do my own thing yeah I mean I think
it had I think it had a ton of influence
and I think that was sure the intention
as well in a lot of ways and like the
way that even down to the way that
you're fighting and you know handling a
sword but also so much time I can speak
for myself but I think it's true for
both of us that like just spent time
thinking about them as parents yeah and
how that affects you as a child and just
yeah just you know who are they and what
is that relationship like so yeah just
tons of time and I think that the
influence probably just filtered in
subconsciously it's also in the writing
totally and I think yeah it was it was
super fun to play with the idea of like
what would I look up to what would I
admire what would I reject what would I
hate growing up with like is
it was super fun to sort of craft their
an easy that we had references it was
easier having references
um of our parents yeah yeah and I see
you know Ruby you play very much into
this sort of night and and Princess
Trope with this I mean you get to be a
literal Disney princess which must be
you know so amazing but what's it like
to sort of be the the emotional core of
the show I guess hmm well I've never
heard it put that way
um
uh
it was it was fun it was really
it was cool to construct such a layered
character such a complicated young woman
I mean she is a Disney princess and but
it's constructing a night a new idea of
what that can mean and someone messy
someone confused someone making mistakes
I think was really cool
um to actually represent and uh yeah I'm
so excited for people to meet kids she
was she's like I wish I had her growing
up honestly and I think my last question
is the original film sort of so many
people see it as this Beacon of like
hope and perseverance do you guys hope
are what do you guys hope that people
take away from this show do you think
that's a great question I think that
definitely what I hope people take away
is in the in the same vein of Hope and
perseverance I think it's like the you
know what I actually think it is it is
the heart and it's positivity but it's
also just the complexity that Ruby was
just talking about where every single
character is three-dimensional and
layered and it's there's no clear-cut
you know hero who knows exactly what
they're doing everybody's struggling and
that's something I think everyone can
take something different from each
character I'm actually curious to see
who people identify with yeah I like
them I'm so excited yeah me too yeah I
agree well thank you guys so much thank
you so much